lo que se asemeja a caer alrededor del Sol.
SD: Exacto, la geometría espacio-tiempo
dice a la Tierra cómo moverse alrededor del Sol.
Ven una aproximación a la perforación de un agujero negro al espacio-tiempo,
y cuando ingresa tan profundamente,
hay un punto en el cual la luz órbita el agujero negro.
CA: Y eso, supongo, es lo pasa aquí.
Esta no es una imagen,
sino una simulación computarizada de lo que pensamos qué es,
como, el horizonte de sucesos alrededor del agujero negro.
SD: Hasta hace una semana, no sabíamos cómo se vería un agujero negro.
Lo mejor que podíamos hacer eran simulaciones así en supercomputadoras,
pero aun así pueden ver el anillo de luz,
que es una órbita de fotones.
Es allí donde los fotones se mueven en el agujero negro,
y a su alrededor está este gas caliente que es atraído al agujero negro,
y está caliente debido a la fricción.
Todo este gas intenta alcanzar un volumen muy pequeño, por eso se calienta.
CA: Años atrás, Uds. se embarcaron en esta misión,
de intentar fotografiar una de estas cosas.
Y supongo que tomó...
se enfocaron en esta galaxia muy lejana.
Cuéntanos de esta galaxia.
SD: Esta es la galaxia.
vamos a hacer un zoom a la galaxia M87, a 55 millones de años luz.
CA: 55 millones.
SD: Es un largo camino.
Y en su centro,
hay un agujero negro de 6,5 mil millones de masa solar.
Es muy difícil de comprender, ¿verdad?
6,5 mil millones de soles comprimidos en un único punto.
Y eso gobierna parte de la energética del centro de la galaxia.
CA: A pesar de que es muy grande, porque está muy alejada,
imaginar conseguir una imagen de él,
es increíblemente difícil.
La resolución necesaria sería increíble.
SD: Los agujeros negros son el objeto más pequeño en el universo conocido.
Pero tienen impresionantes efectos sobre cualquier galaxia.
Para ver uno,
se necesitaría construir un telescopio tan grande como la Tierra,
porque el agujero negro que vemos
emite abundantes ondas de radio.
Las emite todo el tiempo.
CA: Y eso es lo que exactamente hicieron.
SD: Exacto. Lo que ven Uds. aquí
es que usamos telescopios en todo el mundo,
los sincronizamos perfectamente con relojes atómicos,
para recibir las ondas luminosas de este agujero negro,
y luego unimos todos esos datos para construir una imagen.
CA: Para hacerlo
el clima tiene que ser el correcto
en todas estas locaciones al mismo tiempo,
para poder alcanzar una vista limpia.
SD: Tuvimos suerte en muchas formas.
A veces, es mejor tener suerte que ser bueno.
En este caso, me gusta pensar que fueron ambas cosas.
Pero la luz tenía que provenir del agujero negro.
Tenía que venir a través del espacio intergaláctico,
a través de la atmósfera terrestre, donde el vapor del agua puede absorberla,
y todo salió perfecto,
el tamaño de la Tierra en la longitud de la onda de la luz,
es de un milímetro,
era exacta para resolver el agujero negro, a 55 millones de años luz de distancia.
El universo nos decía qué hacer.
CA: Empezaron recolectando gran cantidad de datos.
Creo que esta es la mitad de datos de un solo telescopio.
SD: Sí, ella es un miembro de nuestro equipo, Lindy Blackburn,
y está junto con la mitad de datos
grabados en el Gran Telescopio Milimétrico,
que está sobre una montaña de 4572 m en México.
Y lo que está sosteniendo allí es casi un petabyte.
Lo que, puesto en términos que podamos entender,
es casi el presupuesto de selfis de 5000 personas en toda su vida.
(Risas)
CA: Es mucha información.
Esto fue despachado, no puedes enviar esto por Internet.
Toda esta información fue despachada a un lugar
y los esfuerzos de computadora masiva empezaron a intentar analizarlo.
Y Uds. no sabían realmente
cómo es lo que se vería el resultado.
SD: La forma cómo funciona esta técnica...
imaginen romper un espejo óptico
y poner todos los fragmentos en diferentes lugares.
Un espejo normal funciona
cuando los rayos de luz rebotan en la superficie, lo cual es perfecto,
y se enfocan en un cierto punto al mismo tiempo.
Tomamos todos estos registros,
y con la precisión de un reloj atómico
las alineamos perfectamente en una supercomputadora.
Lo recreamos en un tipo de lente del tamaño de la Tierra.
El único modo de hacerlo es trayendo la información de vuelta por avión.
No pueden vencer el ancho de banda de un 747 lleno de discos duros.
(Risas)
CA: Supongo que hace unas semanas o meses,
en alguna computadora en algún lugar,
esto se empezó a visualizar.
Este momento.
SD: Bien, tomó mucho tiempo.
CA: Miren esto.
Fue esto.
Esta fue la primera imagen.
(Aplausos)
Cuéntanos que estamos viendo aquí.
SD: Aún la amo.
(Risas)
Lo que están viendo es la última órbita de fotones.
Están viendo la geometría de Einstein al descubierto.
La perforación en el espacio-tiempo es tan profunda
que la luz se mueve en órbita,
así que la luz detrás del agujero negro, así como la veremos pronto,
se desplaza y viene hacia nosotros en estas líneas paralelas
en exactamente esa órbita.
Resulta, que esa órbita es la raíz cuadrada de 27
multiplicada por un puñado de constantes fundamentales.
Es extraordinario cuando pensamos en ello.
CA: Cuando...
En mi cabeza, inicialmente, cuando pienso en agujeros negros,
creo que es el horizonte de sucesos,
hay mucha materia y luz girando alrededor en esa forma.
Pero es mucho más complicado que ello.
Cuéntanos a través de esta animación, porque la luz está enfocada sobre ella.
SD: Verán aquí algo de luz detrás de él se enfoca,
y un poco de luz hace un bucle alrededor de la órbita del agujero negro.
Pero cuando hay suficiente luz
de todo este gas caliente girando alrededor del agujero negro,
entonces terminas viendo todos estos rayos de luz
juntándose en esta pantalla,
que es un sustituto de donde tú y yo estamos.
Y se ve la definición de este anillo que comienza a obtener forma.
Y eso es lo que predijo Einstein hace más de 100 años.
CA: Sí, eso es increíble.
Así que dinos más acerca de lo que realmente estamos viendo aquí.
En primer lugar, ¿por qué una parte es más brillante que el resto?
SD: Y, ¿qué está pasando? Es que el agujero negro está girando.
Y terminas con algo de gas moviéndose hacia nosotros por abajo
y retrocediendo de nosotros por la parte superior.
Y así como el silbato del tren. tiene un tono más alto
cuando viene hacia ti,
Hay más energía del gas viniendo que alejándose de nosotros.
Aquí se ve que la parte inferior es más brillante
porque la luz está en realidad impulsada hacia nuestra dirección.
CA: ¿Y cómo es de grande físicamente?
SD: Todo nuestro sistema solar cabría dentro de esa región oscura.
Y si puedo,
esa región oscura es la firma del horizonte de eventos.
La razón por la que no vemos la luz desde allí,
es que la luz que vendría a nosotros desde ese lugar
se la tragó el horizonte de sucesos.
Así que eso es todo.
CA: Y así cuando pensamos en un agujero negro,
pensamos en estos enormes rayos, saliendo de allí,
que son puntiagudos y van directamente hacia nuestra dirección.
¿Por qué no los vemos?
SD: Es un agujero negro muy poderoso.
No por estándares universales, sigue siendo poderoso,
y desde los polos norte y sur de este agujero negro,
pensamos que los jets están llegando.
Pero estamos demasiado cerca para ver realmente toda la estructura del jet,
pero es la base de esos chorros iluminando el espacio-tiempo.
Y eso es lo que se está doblando. alrededor del agujero negro.
CA: Y si estuvieras en una nave espacial. orbitando alrededor de esa cosa,
¿Cuánto tiempo tardarías en dar toda la vuelta?
SD: Primero, daría cualquier cosa por estar en esa nave espacial.
(Risas)
Inscríbeme.
Hay algo llamado, si es que puedo ser laxo por un momento,
órbita circular interna más estable,
en la que la materia puede moverse alrededor de un agujero negro,
antes de entrar en espiral.
Y para este agujero negro, se necesitan entre tres días y alrededor de un mes.
CA: Es muy poderoso, es extrañamente lento en un nivel.
Quiero decir que ni siquiera notarías
cayendo en ese horizonte de sucesos si estuvieras ahí.
SD: Puede que hayas oído algo sobre "espaguetificación"
donde caes en un agujero negro
y el campo gravitacional en tus pies es mucho más fuerte que en tu cabeza,
así que estás destrozado.
Este agujero negro es tan grande
que no te vas a convertir en un fideo de espagueti.
Solo vas a la deriva a través de ese horizonte de sucesos.
CA: Entonces es como un tornado gigante.
Como cuando Dorothy fue azotada por un tornado, ella terminó en Oz.
¿Dónde terminas si caes en un agujero negro?
(Risas)
SD: En Vancouver.
CA: Oh, Dios mío.
(Aplausos)
Es el círculo rojo, eso es aterrador.
No realmente.
SD: Los agujeros negros realmente son el misterio central de nuestra época.
Porque ahí es donde el mundo cuántico y el mundo gravitacional se juntan.
Lo que hay dentro es una singularidad.
Y ahí es donde todas las fuerzas se unifican,
porque la gravedad es lo suficientemente fuerte
para competir con todas las demás fuerzas.
Pero está escondido de nosotros,
el universo lo ha ocultado en la capa de invisibilidad definitiva.
Así que no sabemos qué pasa allí.
CA: Así que hay uno más pequeño de esos en nuestra propia galaxia.
¿Podemos volver a nuestra propia galaxia hermosa?
Esta es la Vía Láctea, este es el hogar.
Y en algún lugar en medio de eso, hay otro
que intentas encontrar también.
SD: Ya sabemos que está ahí, y ya hemos tomado datos de ello.
Y estamos trabajando en esos datos.
Así que esperamos tener algo en un futuro cercano, pero no puedo decir cuándo.
CA: Está muy cerca, pero también es mucho más pequeño,
¿tal vez del tamaño similar del que vimos?
SD: Correcto. Así resulta que el agujero negro en M87,
que vimos antes,
son 6500 millones de masas solares.
Pero está tan lejos que aparece en un cierto tamaño.
El agujero negro en el centro de nuestra galaxia es mil veces menos masivo,
pero también está mil veces más cerca.
Se ve igual de tamaño angular en el cielo.
CA: Finalmente, supongo, un guiño a un notable grupo de personas.
¿Quiénes son estos chicos?
SD: Estos son solo algunos del equipo.
Nos maravillamos ante la repercusión que ha tenido esta imagen.
Si me hubieras dicho que iba a estar en un lugar destacado en todos los periódicos,
no estoy seguro de que lo habría creído, pero así fue.
Porque esto es un gran misterio
y es inspirador para nosotros, y espero inspirador para todos.
Pero lo más importante es que ellos son solo un pequeño número del equipo.
Somos 200 personas con 60 institutos
en 20 países y regiones.
Si quieres construir un telescopio global, necesitas un equipo global.
Y esta técnica que usamos de enlazar telescopios alrededor del mundo
es una forma de eludir sin esfuerzo algunos de los temas que nos dividen.
Y como científicos, naturalmente, es unirnos para hacer algo como esto.
CA: Guau, eso es inspirador para todo nuestro equipo esta semana.
Shep, muchas gracias por lo que hiciste. y por venir aquí.
SD: Gracias
(Aplausos)